[Music]
this is it Albert welcome to the jungle
we are on secret grants right now
you're just beginning to see it's part
of the structures I've never seen
anything like this
welcome to nan Madol only a tiny
fragment of the legendary Saudi lower
city can still be seen mangroves choke
whatever else remains now new technology
can help unlock the secrets of this
place how and why it was built and just
how big it really is it's incredible
innit
I was born here but every time I come up
here I'm always amazed always this is
the main ceremonial center of Nana dog
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a temple to the islands ancient
rulers constructed from pillars of
basalt rock eight hundred years ago this
place would have been bustling with
hundreds of priests attendants and the
feared saddle or kings
must be some superpower humans to build
this huh well this area was meant only
for daily it was the only time in our
history that we were ruled by one person
almost like a dictator so he was able to
command all the people on the island to
come and assist in the building of an
adult because that more rocks over there
well that's another wall build all the
way to the edge of the reef yeah you can
see the reef breaking right there
exactly
it's massive to get to grips with this
city in the sea we need to work out the
full extent of it and that can only be
done from above I think we have to scan
this you know with the drone and maybe
we can start to really map out all these
different features there are nine people
are structures all man-made from here
all the way down south yes all the way
there yes such a huge area it is you
can't see anything it's all mangrove but
the mangroves near 800 years ago you
know it's been abandoned for a long time
so the bankers just could have been easy
to map it then it is now well that's
maybe a lighter Bank rooms take it off
my drone team begin the first of more
than 40 planned flights we're scanning
this whole area almost half a square
mile twice the size of the Vatican City
we want to strip back the jungle canopy
and reveal the rest of this city
[Music]
we're going back to explore the gigantic
building that Gus showed me to find out
more about the people who built this
place
why is there so little known about
people that built this incredible
monument the reason there are so little
notes because there's not a written
system to express ideas it was through
oral tradition which airs towards
exactly those are stories handed down
generation to generation and no person
can tell the entire story because
there's the belief that if they tell the
whole story that they will die they're
no longer useful how is this place bill
I can't imagine how a human effort could
actually carry these stones all the way
up to the top of this building it's
really not clear to us how it was done
the physics part of it one legend talks
about magic being used to lift the rocks
and bring them over here so they would
fly magic flew these rocks here that's
right this whole expedition is something
else I'm a scientist a technologist I
deal in facts finding out how they
actually built this it's gonna be a
challenge
[Music]